Sophia Carson speaks out following the
death of Cameron boys a little over a
week after the Disney Channel star died
the actors penned a heartbreaking
tribute dedicated to her late co-star
who died in his sleep on July 6th
following a seizure the 26 year old took
to Instagram posting this
black-and-white photo of boys saying in
part quote to our angel there are not
enough words there will never be enough
words adding I couldn't bring myself to
do this because doing this makes it real
letting you go is not something I know
how to do and I just can't fathom living
in a world without you I love you cam
and I will love you forever
his father debby ryan and dove Cameron
are among the many who have spoken out
in the wake of Cameron's death Disney
Channel announced The Descendants three
premiere planned for July 22nd was
cancelled oh don't you ever miss
screaming at people and just making them
run away from you you're thinking of my
mother and I was usually on the other
end of that so not really no Cameron was
known for starring in several Disney
Channel projects including The
Descendants franchise where he played
the role of Carlos the son of karela de
ville ET spoke with Cameron in 2017
weeks before the second Descendants film
debuted how'd it be up the ante fer the
second it's gonna be difficult honestly
right because I mean the first one was
really big and when we first heard about
you know we were doing a sequel we were
like all right how are we gonna top the
first one but I think we did I think
that everything is bigger the sets the
the choreography the numbers all of it
is a really high energy and high stakes
and stuff like that so it's pretty it's
pretty fun